Migration das Thema überhaupt in den USA
mal wieder schon 2016 als wir dort das
erste mal ausführlicher gedreht haben
haben wir das als als das Thema dort
erlebt und und manchmal geht's ein
bisschen kalt den Rücken runter weil wir
damals überlegt haben alles was in den
USA passiert ist ungefähr 10 Jahre
später auch Thema bei uns die 10 Jahre
sind ziemlich genau rum haben sie bei
dem Thema etwas nicht sehen wollen was
sie aus ideologischen Gründen nicht
sehen
wollten Seite passiert ja gerade ganz
viel im migrationspolitischen Bereich
sowohl in der Frage wie wir Fachkräfte
an als auch die Frage kontrollee von den
letzten 10 Jahren ab der der Blick mal
aufs große Ganze das wird mich mal
interessieren da waren sie ja zum Teil
noch gar nicht in in Amt und Würden mir
geht's nur darum mal zu verstehen an
welchem Punkt würden sie selbstkritisch
sagen das haben wir komplett falsch
eingeschätzt das würde ich tatsächlich
bei diesem Thema nicht sagen ich glaube
dass Deutschland sehr lange sich nicht
aktiv mit seiner Rolle als
Einwanderungsland auseinandergesetzt
wird als Migration wurde ein bisschen
beh als irgendwas was ein passiert was
man aushalten muss aber eigentlich
nichts als das was man aktiv gestaltet
das haben wir jetzt verändert mit der
Ampel das hat verschiedenste Facetten
vom Fachkraft der einwandungsgesetz bis
tatsächlich auch zum
europäischenelsystem aber die die Frage
ich glaube wenn wir wirklich darüber
reden was man verpasst hat dann ist das
mal etwas anderes als auf ein einzelnes
Thema zu schauot noch bitte wür gerne
einmal bei dem Thema bleiben und lass
uns versuchen da einmal konzentriert
weil hier kluge Leute sitzen einmal ganz
konzentriert durchzugehen sie als Chefin
der Grünen mm W sagen wir als Grüne
haben bei dem Thema Migration nichts
falsch gemacht niemand hat bei keinem
Thema was falsch Gemach ist die Floskel
aus Text das ist keine Floskel aber
natürlich hat niemand be ke Thema keine
Fehler gemacht ich glaube nur dass die
Hinleitung darüber das leitet sich vor
allem aus Migration ab und deshalb muss
man jetzt einfach dort Herter V die
würde ich nicht teilen was wir sehen ist
dass dort mit einem emotionalen Angebot
gearbeitet wird und dieses emotionale
Angebot ist du bist gut weil du einer
von uns bist und nicht wie die anderen
nicht wie die Flüchtlinge nicht wie die
Migranten nicht wie die da oben und was
wir als Demokratie finde ich ernsthaft
verpasst haben ist dem ein eigenes
emotionales Angebot entgegenzusetzen du
bist gut weil du gebraucht wirst du bist
gut weil du was bewegen
kannst ja natürlich wir sehen doch
gerade ne wir sehen Umbruchphasen das
haben wir gerade besprochen hier wir
sehen wie sich die Demokratien behaupten
müssen international dies unbruchphasen
sind für viele Menschen mit Ängsten
beschäftigt diese unbruchphasen sind für
viele Menschen mit Unsicherheiten
behaftet und ich glaube dass auf diese
Unsicherheiten die Rechten eine sehr
einfache Antwort haben und das ist die
anderen sind schuld die da draußen sind
schuld und wir verteidigen dich gegen
die ich glaube nicht dass wir jetzt
Demokraten richtig damit fahren dem
einfach hinterher zu laufen tut ja
gerade zum Glück auch wir nicht in der
Ampel aber was man tatsächlich tun muss
ist den Leuten eigenes Angebot für
Sicherheit zu geben und auch ein
Zugehörigkeitsgefühl nicht über
Abgrenzung nach außen oder nach oben
sondern über wir kriegen das zusammen
hin Michael Brücker schüttelt schon den
Kopf und mich wde interessieren warum wo
fangen wir an ja nee aber wir bleiben
bei der Migration aus meiner Sicht sehr
gerne weil für mich ist das und man kann
über viele Politik Handlungsfelder der
Grünen so oder so reden aber bei der
Migrationspolitik ist es aus meiner
Sicht wirklich offensichtlich es gab
eine wünscht dir was Rhetorik und
Kommunikation und auch Priorisierung der
Grünen in den letzten 10 15 Jahren von
wegen das ist ein Wirtschaftswunder was
da kommt das sind alles äh tolle junge
Menschen die uns bereichern ich brauche
i diese ziteater alle gar nicht äh gar
nicht vorhalten sie kennen die alle
besser das Problem bei der
Migrationspolitik ist nicht dass Sie
immer sofort auf eine emotionale
Metaebene geben sondern konkrete Politik
es ist eine willkürliche es ist eine
irrationale und es ist eine sehr
wünschte was Politik gemacht worden in
der Migration Frage bis hin zu das
Äußerung wie Begrenzung bei grünen
Politikern gar nicht zum
standardrepertoir gehören dürfen weil
das dann schon ausgrenzend ist dass
Menschen Sozialsysteme einwandern wird
teilweise negiert bei euch und dass dann
jetzt sogar darüber diskutiert wird do
dass ein abschiebegesetz in der Ampel
das zu 600 Abschiebungen laut
Gesetzentwurf in Deutsch schon führen
soll dass das selbst doch mal diskutiert
wird 600 mehr was ja ein Witz ist
angesichts der der tatsächlichen Fälle
ihr habt die Deutschen und deswegen auch
gerade die Mehrheit der Grünen gut
gestimmten potenziellen Wählerin
enttäuscht dass wir bei diesem zentralen
Thema nicht ehrlich wart weder in der
Kommunikation noch in der Handlung ihr
habt eure Politik bei dem Thema ja nicht
verändert wollt es bis heute nicht tun
und das ist echt der Grund warum die
Grünen nicht mehr bei 25 sind sondern
bei 12% ist tatsächlich die aus meiner
Sicht naiv und widersprüchliche
Migrationspolitik über alles andere kann
man diskutieren aber hier folgen euch
die Mehrheit der Leute wirklich nicht
mehr selbst die die euch wohl gesonnen
sind also erstmal müsste man ja sagen
wenn wir als grünne dazu geführt hatten
dass das Land da steht wo es steht bei
Migration wir waren bis vor zwei Jahren
überhaupt gar nicht in der Regierung das
heißt das ist ja erstmal glaube ich
nicht dass man das gerade auf das grüne
Erbe runterbrechen kann und was unsere
Linie in der Migrationspolitik ist das
haben wir immer wieder formuliert heißt
Humanität und Ordnung das heißt
natürlich braucht es Ordnung natürlich
werden Grenzen kontrolliert übrigens was
was gerade europäisch an der
europäischen Außengrenze natürlich
passiert das wird jetzt auch eingeführt
noch mal über das Screening und vor
allem auch mit schrittweise zu einem
toal Verfahren passiert nichts jeder der
nach Europa kommt darf in Europa bleiben
und ihr wollt dieylverfahren außerhalb
der EU nicht das einzig wahrscheinlich
echt wirksam Instrument laut aller
Experten ist für euch ein inhumanes
moralisch schwieriges und deswen rede
gerade noch nicht meh Moralität sondern
ich rede darüber dass Großbritannien das
versucht hat mit dem Ruanda Modell
vorgeschlagen hat dass asülbewerbe die
bei Ihnen ankommen einfach direkt
abgekartt werden nach Ruanda gebracht
werden jetzt hat das britische Supreme
Court wir können davon ausgehen dass die
europäischen Gerichte hinausurteilen
werden klar gesagt das ist rechtswidrig
das ist
nicht nicht das System und nicht das
Modell ist re rechtswiig so Ruanda
bietet nicht die Voraussetzung für so
ein Land nicht das System nicht das
Modell ist rechtswiedrig nur dass Randa
nicht das richtige Land ist das ist das
einzige wasurteil
gesagt die Leute die leute Leute sollen
das verstehen was wir hier besprechen
das das oberste britische Gericht hat
nicht gesagt Ruanda also die Idee
sozusagen Menschen nach Ruanda zu
bringen dort als Asylverfahren
durchzuführen ist per se rechtswidrig
sondern rechtswidrig ist die Möglichkeit
dass das Justizsystem in Ruanda okay so
damit überfordert oder tendenziös oder
was auch immer sein könnte heißt mit
anderen Worten wenn das vielleicht die
UN oder wer auch immer übernehmen reden
wir über eine ganz andere Geschichte
mich würde aber etwas anderes
interessieren weil man kann sich
dahinter ja auch leicht verstecken mich
würde interessieren Asylverfahren
außerhalb Europas mit ihnen machbar oder
nicht ich habe mich da schon mal
geäußert dazu dass ich das fast nicht
für machbar halte WST überhaupt gar
nicht über welche Länder wir reden und
wir haben die Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention das ist ein sehr
sehr starkes Recht das ja auch nicht
ohne Grund eingeführt wurde das aus eine
historischen Notwendigkeit das sagt
erstmal hat jeder das Recht sich auf den
Weg zu machen und dass SE Antrag
individuell geprüft wird in dem Land wo
er ankommt und das ist nichts was man
einfach zur Seite schieben kann oder was
man dann als moralischenbim anun kann
sit wir uns auseinandersetzen
msenche Realität seit 10 15 Jahren das
funktioniert ja genauso und funktioniert
so genauso nicht ne was die politische
Realität ist dass wir es in Europa nicht
geschafft haben jetzt gehen wir einzelne
Schritte auch wenn ich viele Schritte
z.B Solidarität für größer notwendige
gehalten hätte ist dass wir es nicht
geschafft haben einen vernünftigen
Umgang damit zu finden es wurden
teilweise an der Grenze die Leute
einfach durchgelassen das stimmt ja da
lich es haben sich sehr viele Länder aus
der Verantwortung übernommen überhaupt
aufzunehmen und man hat kein gemeinsamen
verteilmechanismus bekommen aber das ist
doch das ich glaube nicht das
funktionieren wird zu sagen das Problem
schieben wir jetzt einfach ab das
verlagern wir in andere Länder sondern
wir müssen es hier in Europa hinbekommen
dass erstens die Grenzen kontrolliert
werden dass zweitens die Menschen
verteilt werden und dass wir drittens
dann schnelle Verfahren haben wo
geschaut wird wer kann bleiben he
Grenzkontrolle was machen Sie mit dem
einen Menschen der dann auf
europäischenem Grund und Boden
Grenzkontrolle leider kein Pass mehr was
machen sie dann D werden die Daten
erstmal aufgenommen da wo sie Verhalten
sind sonst muss das natürlich nach geh
und dann wird der von der Bundespolizei
zur nächsten flterkunft gebracht das ist
eine wie die Bundespolizisten sagen ein
shuttleverfahren ein Taxi dann bringen
die den dahin und das war's und dann
kommen die Verfahren die dauern
natürlich zu lange darüber können wir
alle reden aber es gibt keinen einzigen
Vorschlag der Grünen in Deutschland für
eine Begrenzung der Migration in Europa
ich kenne ihn nicht sagen sie ihn mir
das was täich dazu führen W dass weniger
Menschen h ankommen wäre wenn wir
europäisch besser verteilen das ist der
Weg das andere llich wir haben einfach
LZ fr ich kann die doch nicht zwingen
dazu die wollen nicht ganz Europa will
diesäis natürlich gemeinsame Lösungen
finden das ist ja auch die Voraussetzung
also gan aber das sie beschreiben das
gerade so das was wir gerade tun an der
europäischen Grenze das funktioniert
alles nicht aber die Vorstellung dass
andere Länder od diese Länder Ruanda hat
z.B in diesem Fall gesagt geringste
Mengen überhaupt nur machen können wo
wir dann nicht mal wissen wie dort die
Rechtsordnung funktioniert das soll
plötzlich super praktikabel und einfach
umsetzbar Verteilung funktioniert seit
10 Jahren nicht in Europa warum soll die
denn jetzt funktionier jetzt gehen wir
ersten Schritt mit
solidaritätsmechanismus ganz kurz genau
würd gerne mal auf die andere Ebene
sozusagen kommen weil wir drehen uns da
auch ehrlich gesagt seit seit fast
Bestehen dieser Sendung in genau diesem
Kreis sie sagen Herr Geiges da gibt es
eine tiefe kulturelle Entfremdung ich
habe heute ein Interview mit Nil
Ferguson gelesen britischer Historiker
der in in den USA lehrt und der sagt das
ist genau das Thema immer um das es geht
genau das diese riesige Entfremdung
zwischen den politischen Eliten und dem
was man sozusagen das normale das das
einfache Volg nennt und zwar auf genau
diesen beiden Feldern das eine das Thema
Migration wir haben einfach nicht
verstanden wie sehr der Schuh ganz
konkret gerade am unteren Ende der
Gesellschaft bei den Leuten drückt
und und das andere Thema ist schlicht
und ergreifend die Frage dass du alles
sozusagen sofort für rassistisch
erklärst wenn jemand sagt was auf wir
müssen jetzt mal ein paar Dinge als
Gesellschaft einfach verhandeln wird
dann einfach als rassistisch irgendwie
weggepackt und geächtet und damit bist
du raus aus dem Diskurs würden Sie sagen
da hat er recht sowohl Herr Geiges als
auch Herr fergerson sie auch jetzt
wieder ich erlebe das hier saßen grüne
Landräte mm die haben gesagt es mir
jetzt völlig egal welches Parteibuch ich
habe aber das geht so nicht weiter wir
schaffen es schlicht und ergreifend
nicht und wie Herr Brücker sagte selbst
die die guten Willens sind die
sagen Dach überm Kopf ein Bett das ist
vielleicht ir wie eine Unterkunft aber
das ist keine Integration haben die
keine Ahnung doch natürlich haben die
Ahnung die erleben das ja in der Praxis
n ganz e warum hören Sie den das was ich
will ist dass wir eine realistische
Migrationspolitik haben und dann müssen
wir uns auch damit auseinandersetzen was
funktioniert
tatsächlich auch sehr sehr einfache
Antworten wo man denkt das Problem
können wir einfach irgendwo anders
hinbringen und wenn wir realistische
Migrationspolitik sprechen dann müssen
wir auch schauen wo gibt es tatsächlich
Probleme da gibt es welche sie haben
gesagt hier saßen schon viele Leute die
das auch gesagt haben das ist
Überforderung der Kommunen da müssen wir
schauen was unterstützt die Kommunen am
schnellsten am einfachsten das ist
finanzielle Unterstützung doch natürlich
auch natürlich son hät do der Städtetag
das nicht
auff ist die Frage dass wir die Menschen
sehr sehr schnell dass wir die Menschen
sehr sehr schnell in Arbeit bringen denn
das ist am besten die besteung warum
funktioniert nicht wä mit ihnen eine
Arbeit dann drehen wir es um ich ich
würde gerne die Frage dazu stellen wä
mit ihnen eine Arbeitspflicht zu machen
es geht doch erstmal darum dass die
Leute arbeiten dür es gibt ja jetzt wir
werden tatsächlich wurden doch im Rahmen
der Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bereits
schon beschlossen dass auf den Weg
gebracht wird dass auch sowas wie eine
verpflichtende ehrenamtliche Arbeit
möglich sein soll aber ich wünsche mir
dass die Leute ich wünsche mir dass die
Leute in sozialversicherungspflichtige
Jobs kommen den wir haben einen riesigen
fachkang dies Land und wir müssen
schauen dass die Leute die H ankommen wo
das möglich ist das wird nicht bei allen
möglich sein aber ich glaube bei mehr
ich meine bei der Ukraine haben wir doch
gesehen das sind andere Leute deutlich
besser darin die Leute in Arbeit zu
bringen dass sie schnell arbeiten dürfen
dann Vermittlung haben ich sie haben
vorhin gesagt für die Migrationspolitik
der letzten 10 Jahre sind wir nicht
verantwortlich da haben sie in Teilen
recht für Thema Ukraine die Frage warum
wir so wenige Ukrainer Ukrainerinnen
sind ja vor allen Dingen in den
Arbeitsmarkt kriegen sind sie sehr wohl
verantwortlich nicht Sie persönlich aber
ihre Politik äh Niederlande 60% die dort
arbeiten Polen 90% Deutschland keine
20%. woran liegt das Bürokratie es ist
in Deutschland viel zu bürokratisch wie
ich eigentlich in einen Job kommen kann
was wird anerkannt an Möglichkeiten was
Sie vielleicht schon ein Ausbildung
mitbringen wie schnell komm weil das ein
sehr sehr komplizierte Prozess aber
genau das müssen wir jetzt ändern und
das sind wir auch dran wir müssen die
Ausländerbehörden viel viel besser
aufstellen wir müssen die Verfahren
massiv beschleunigen wir müssen
Arbeitsverbot und das tun wird Schritt
für Schritt abschaffen damit es
tatsächlich Mens auch möglich wird und
ich glaube was tatsächlich ein Schlüssel
ist das ist die Anerkennung von
Abschlüssen wenn ich mit Menschen rede
und da kann man mit Leuten in PLE geheim
reden die sagen mir na ja ich habe hier
eine Brasilianerin die ist da die will
arbeiten aber die kann nicht anfangen
weil ihr Abschluss erst im Jahr
anerkannt wird das ist doch Wahnsinn
dafür hat niemand verständlich die würde
Steuern zahlen die würde ein Job
übernehmen die würde damit auch alte
Menschen unterstützen ich glaube dass
das tatsächlich sehr sehr pragmatische
sehr konkrete Sachen sind schnellere
Anerkennung von Abschlüssen bessere
Ausstattung von den Ausländerbehörden
und aber auch die Abschaffung von
arbeitsverb so andere Frage die direkt
dazu führt weil hier ein studierter
Volkswirt auch sitzt kann es sein dass
es sich gar nicht lohnt in Deutschland
zu arbeiten ist das das nächste Thema
über das wir reden müssen jedenfalls ist
also es gibt gibt V vom ifo Institut
eine sehr interessante Projektion die
sagt es macht in München beispielsweise
als vierköpfige Familie überhaupt keinen
Unterschied ob du 3500 € Verdienst oder
5000 € Verdienst weil du durch
entsprechende aufstockungsmöglichkeiten
sozusagen ganz schnell auf diese auf
diese 5000 € genauso kommen kannst das
heißt du triffst selber die Entscheidung
ob du diese 1500 € Differenz verdienen
möchtest oder nicht wenn du es tust
arbeitest du sehr lange für einen
vergleichsweise niedrigen Mindestlohn um
das irgendwie hinzukriegen und wenn du
es nicht tust geht's auch so und wenn
ich Einatz sagen darf li das ist das
Problem es ist nicht die Bürokratie es
ist nicht das gild das ist eine
Grundhaltung eine ökonomische
Grundhaltung dieser Politik das
Arbeitsanreize nicht im Zentrum stehen
sondern die Alimentation das ist das das
ist schlicht die Wahrheit die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge sind auch
deswegen nicht so schnell in die Arbeit
gekommen nicht weil sie bürokratisch
Hörden haben sondern weil sie erstmal
sofort das Bürgergeld bekommen haben und
die den Notwendigkeit gar nicht erst
sahen eine von den 4 Millionen offenen
Job die wir dringend in diesem Land
besetzt haben müssen in Anspruch zu
nehmen und das ist das Grundproblem beim
Bürgergeld ist nicht das ein der
einzelne Tarif das Thema sondern das
Gesamtpaket es lohnt sich kaum
aufzustehen es sind wenige 100 € mehr
zwischen einer Geringverdiener Familie
und einer bürgergeldfamilie und wenn und
zwar nur dann wenn sie staatliche
Unterstützung wie Wohngeld zusätzlich in
Anspruch nehmen was auch nicht jeder der
jeden Tag arbeitet gerne noch zusätzlich
beim Amt abholen will aber wenn sie das
machen selbst dann sind es nur wenige
100 € Unterschied und das verstehen die
Menschen nicht wenn im gleichen Haus
eine Etage tiefer jemand gar nicht
arbeitet und ich bringe mit in einem 10
Stunden Job am Ende 3 oder 400 € mehr
nach Hause das ist ein zentrales Problem
will ich Menschen in Job haben Rente mit
63 ist das andere Ende
vorruhestandsprogramm der Politik wird
auch nicht abgeschafft von der Ampel
hätte man längst machen müssen wir
wollen offenbar die Leute nicht in Jobs
bringen sondern wir wollen sie dort
behalten wo sie sind damit Sie sich
möglichst wohlfühlen und da machen wir
ein rundum wohlfühl sozialstaatspaket
und das ist leider alle Ökonomen sehen
es inzwischen so ist inzwischen echtes
Problem in diesem
Land
großeierung weil die ich meine das Geld
das verteilt wird Bürgergeld z.B an an
Leute jetzt auch egal woher schon lange
hier wohnen oder kürz hier wohnen die
aber noch nie gearbeitet haben das ist
ja nicht ihr
Geld
genauich und und das ist halt be jetzt
die Bauern ich meine die sagen halt uns
wird das Geld jetzt weggenommen weil
angeblich kein Geld da ist aber für alle
möglichen anderen Leute die nicht
arbeiten ist Geld da aber da muss ich
mal sagen ich glaube dass dieser Modus
nach unten Tretens uns nicht
weiterbringt wir können nicht
Interessenskonflikte die real vorhanden
sind mit nach unten treten nutzen denn
ganz ehrlich kein Bauer hat eine bessere
Perspektive sein Hof weil überülbewerber
hergezogen wird kein Mensch
Niedriglohnsektor arbeitet natürlich hab
kein Mensch Niedriglohnsektor arbeitet
kann seine Miete besser bezahlen weil
die Menschen im Bürgergeld schlechter
gestellt werden und deshalb finde ich in
so einer Situation geht es nicht um nach
unten treten denn am Ende ist eine
Politik nach unten treten Politik von
rtim eine faule Politik dass mich nicht
hinstell und sage ich löse das aktive
Problem sondern dass man sich hinstellt
und im Zweifelsfall sich wegduckt auch
vor diesen Debatten und wenn wir über
die ökonomischen Anreize sprechen wenn
wir tatsächlich darüber sprechen wie
können wir für sorgens Menschen Arbeit
kommen dann reden wir darüber dann reden
wir über tarifbezahlung also z. mit
einem mE ein tarifreue Gesetzt dafür
sorgen würden dass mehr Menschen
Deutschland nach Tarif bezahlt werden
also mehr Geld am Ende des Monats haben
dann reden wir über höheren Mindestlohn
also was ist eigentlich mit den Menschen
die tatsächlich an diesen unteren Grenze
sind dann reden wir über mietenpolitik
denn das ist bei ganz vielen Menschen
eines der Hauptprobleme sowohl die
Mietpreise als auch mittlerweile die
Grundstückpreise wenn sich jemand
vielleicht ein kleines Häuschen kaufen
will das heißt dass die der Teil von dem
was vom Einkommen übrig bleibt dass das
immer geringer wird als WN reden wir
eine über eine soziale Politik die sich
den Problemen stellt aber nicht so tut
als ob irgendwas besser wird indem wir
auf die Bürgergeld schauen noch mal
Fragen konkret nachfragen sie haben
versprochen dass sie 100.000 neue
Sozialwohnungen jedes Jahr bauen noch
mal nicht Sie persönlich aber diese
ampelregierung von der die Grünen ein
Teil sind sie schaffen das hinten und
vorne nicht es fehlen aktuell 910 000
Sozialwohnungen in
Deutschland das ist ein riesen Problem
was nicht steht zwischen dem Gefühl es
geht ungerecht zu in diesem Land weil es
sich nicht mehr so richtig lohnt
irgendwie äh sich wirklich
anzustrengen führt möglicherweise auch
eine Linie hin zu dem Erfolg der AFD
würden Sie mir zustimmen wenn ich sage
der Erfolg der AFD hat nichts mit der
AFD zu tun sondern der Erfolg der AFD
kommt vor allen Dingen daher dass sie
einen Misserfolg eine Pleite um es mal
sozusagen nach der anderen hinlegen
nicht Sie persönlich noch mal aber diese
ampelregierung ich glaub da muss man
zwei Dinge unterscheiden das erste das
haben sie jetzt auch gar nicht gemacht
dass man glaube ich nicht anfangen kann
das was die AFD tut in irgendeiner Form
als Protest abzutun das haben wir jetzt
gerade noch mal ganz klar gesehen mit
den korrektivrecherchen dass Teile der
Massen Deportationen planen als
tatsächlich sich auch an faschistischen
umsturzfantasien beteiligen g
Entschuldigung Kulturkampf nicht mal das
schadet den und die Debatte über ein
Verbot hilft Ihnen und die Tatsache dass
wir hier im Fernsehen darüber reden und
uns beklagen und sagen da gibt es diese
diese die diese diese bösen Faschisten
da müssen wir ganz harte Kante hilft den
immer weiter ich hab noch gar nicht
Verbot gesprochen ich glaube schon dass
es wichtig ist dass wir einmal
aussprechen was dort auf den Tisch
gelegt wird auch weil es Signal ist an
die Menschen dieavon betroffen sind denn
wir schauen uns mal an was die planen
die Planen nicht irgendwelche
Verschärfung bei bestimmten
migrationspolitischen Fragen sondern
dass Menschen die hier leben die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft haben dass
die aus dem Land geschafft werden dass
die deportiert werden das auszusprechen
einzelne Funktionäre auch der mit
rechtsextrem Akteuren das auszusprechen
halte ich für absolut notwendig weil es
auch ein Signal ist an die Menschen die
hier leben die hier Steuern zahlen die
hier Familien haben dass wir ganz klar
sagen wir stellen uns vor euch wir
werden euch schützen wir machen keinen
Unterschied in Staatsbürger erste und
zweite Klasse egal ob du jetzt cordola
oder Samira heißt und gleichzeitig und
das geht vielleicht auf ihren Punkt ein
stimmt es dass es ein Fehler wäre wenn
jetzt die demokratischen Parteien
anfangen interess Blick auf die Wahlen
im Herbst neun Monate lang darüber zu
reden wie schlimm alles ist wie
furchtbar alles ist und sich in so einer
lamoyan beschwören das schlimmer der
schlimmen Lage und allgemeinen
Beschwörung zur Demokratie verlieren
würden s ich glaub wenn es darum geht
die Demokratie verteiligen müssen wir
als demokratische Parteien besser werden
ich würde dafür drei Dinge sehen das
erste ist sehr ins Konkrete gehen nicht
im ganz abstrakten verlieren wenn wir
über Modernisierung reden ja genau sie s
konkret ich versuche es auch zu sein
sehr konkret darüber zu reden wenn wir
über Wirtschaft reden was bringt's den
Leuten welche Jobs entstehen wie kann
man dafür leben das zweite ist die Frage
vom Dasein zuhören wir haben
mittlerweile landschnitte wo
demokratische Parteien kaum noch
sichtbar sind und das verändert was und
das Schiß dieses Bild von die da oben
die mit denen ich nichts zu tun habe die
sich eh nicht für mich interessieren
glaube dass wir sehr darauf schauen
müssen in der Fläche präsent zu sein
Debatten zu führen nicht nur die großen
Demos in Berlin sondern da was wichtig
ist und das letzte ist Punkt mit
Emotionalität wir dürfen ein emotionales
Angebot nicht den rechtstrem überlassen
also entschuldigung Sie sie sie
argumentieren aus schließlich
emotional psychologisch handfest ganz
konkret mm in ihrer Ampelkoalition wird
so viel von Respekt gesprochen mm
verstehen sie nicht dass es einen
Zusammenhang gibt zwischen irregulärer
Migration offenbar nicht gesteuert und
der Tatsache dass am unteren Ende 910
000 Sozialwohnungen fehlen das Mieten
ständig steigen das Häuser steigen dass
Wohnungen steigen dass die Inflation
nach oben getrieben wird dass Schulen
nicht mehr funktionieren ich habe dieser
Tage mit einer Grundschullehrerin
gesprochen die sagte pass auf ich habe
16 Kinder denst dir gratuliere 16 Kinder
geht ja noch aber von diesen 16 Kindern
sprechen sechs Deutsch so dritte Klasse
dass man mit ih Unterricht machen kann
und dann kommt noch ein 17es Kind
plötzlich dazu ein armes bulgarisches
Mädchen das kein Wort Deutsch spricht
und sie sagt wenn ich gut bin schaffe
ich zwei Stunden Unterricht am Tag das
ist niemand und ich erlebe so viele
solcher Leute den in irgendeiner Nähe
zur AFD oder sonst was unterwegs wäre
sondern das sind wohlmeinende sehr
engagierte Menschen die versuchen
irgendwie diesen Laden am Laufen zu
halten sagen nee so wie das gerade läuft
kann ich das nicht mehr das ist konkrete
Politik ist das nicht eine Form von
Respektlosigkeit wenn man das einfach
dann abtut und sagt pass auf dann müssen
wir ein bisschen mehr reden da müssen
wir Debatten führen müssen wir zuhören
dann müssen wir ein emotionales Angebot
machen die braucht kein emotionales
Angebot die braucht jemand der ihr
Problem mit der mit dem kleinen Mädchen
aus Bulgarien löst klar das hab davon
dass wir konkret werden müssen müssen
aber auchen das glaube ich gerade der
ten ja sehr klar gezeigt für USA bei der
Debatte um Migration mischen sich reale
Probleme die existieren mit einer Art
von dämonisierungen vor allem auch eine
Art die jeglichen an jeglichen FAK
lassen das zu wenn sie diese Umstände
zulassen nein ich glaube wir lassen das
zu und S ehlichweise da muss die Ampel
auch besser werden indem wir nicht auch
in diese soziale Infrastruktur
investieren denn das stimmt ja wir haben
Probleme Bildungsbereich schauen das ist
gar keine Frage wir haben Problem mit
Lehrern die überfordert sind die zu
viele Kinder haben die dann auch noch
fünf verschiedene Aufgaben den letzten
Jahren drauf bekommen haben muss sich
noch um Inklusion kümmern muss sich um
das Thema Einwanderung kümmern und die
Frage wie wir das lösen ist aber aus
meiner Sicht vor allem in dem wir
soziale Infrastruktur reingehen also wie
können wir und jetzt nehmen wir das ganz
konkrete Beispiel sie haben den
Bildungsbereich angesprochen wir haben
in Deutschland was das nennt sich
kooperationsfbot also wir leben in einem
föderalen Staat und das ist verboten das
Bund und länd insbesondere wenn es um
Investitionen geht bei der Bildung
zusammenarbeiten das macht überhaupt gar
keinen Sinn wir müssten das umdrehen und
sagen es gibt ein gboot also Bund und
Länder müssen zusammenarbeiten auch eine
Frage von gleichwertigen
Lebensverhältnissen das wäre sehr
konkret was wir mehr in die soziale
Infrastruktur investieren von denen dann
übrigens auch alle Menschen profitieren
egal ob sie zugewandert sind oder ob sie
es nicht sind und das ist übrigens auch
eine Frage bei der Vermittlung in die
Arbeit denn wir haben ja real sowas beim
Arbeitsmarkt man kN sagen matching
Problem also getil Arbeitsmarkt wir
haben auf der einen Seite massiven
Fachkräftemangel und auf der anderen
Seite eine Gruppe die ist nicht riesig
aber sie verfestigt sich von Menschen
die gar kein Arbeitsplatz mehr finden
jetzt muss man schauen woraus besteht
die zum großen Teil das sind sehr sehr
großer Teil Jugendliche die die Schule
ohne einen Abschluss verlassen haben
sind glaube ich 2,6 Millionen Kinder im
Jahr wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe
und bei denen ist die Arbeitslosenquote
2,6 nichtlich im Jahr 2,6 Millionen
insgesamt in
Deutschland haben 50 die Jugendliche
leisten uns jedes Jahr 50 bis 60 000
insgesamt
2,6 die ohne Schule ohneen Abschuss die
Schule verlassen haben bei denen ist die
Arbeitslosenquote bei ca 19,6% wenn ich
das richtig im Kopf habe da müssen wir
ganz konkret hinschauen wie können wir
die Jugendlichen abholen wie können wir
Bundesagentur für Arbeit nutzen wie
können wir die Schulen da auch Stärken
an dieser Stelle wie können wir die
Realität des Arbeitsmarkt in die Schule
holen das sind dann reale debatten wie
wir tatsächlich den fachkräftte
bekämpfen und auch mehr Gerechtigkeit
schaffen du B auch zzial die
grundschulleherin hat ein konkretes
Problem und sie antworten mit
föderalismusparagraphen sind jetzt bei
Aufstieg das Problem dieser
grundschulllehrerin war zehn von meinen
16 Kindern können kein Deutsch oder ich
krieg sie nicht ins Deutsch als Karsten
Lindemann der CDU Generals damals war es
so nicht vor z Jahren im Sommer einen
Vorschlag gemacht hat wir müssen jetzt
mal sprachpflicht oder Deutschpflicht in
der Grundschule wir brauchen
Sprachstandserhebung wurde der
öffentlich zerhächselt und ich kann ihn
die grünen Politiker nennen die als
allererstes auf dem Markt waren in den
Medien waren und gesagt haben ein
unmöglicher Vorschlag über die
Sprachfähigkeit der Grundschüler
überhaupt zu reden aus zugewanderten
Familien das Problem ist immer sobald
man mit einem konkreten Problem kommt
kommen die Grünen auf die Metaebene
sprechen über Emotion sprechen über
Duktus und das ist nein aber ich glaube
wirklich das beste antifd Programm wäre
eine widerspruchsfreie realistische
ideologiefreie Politik der Ampel dann
wären die von 20 bei 10 dann hast du
immer noch ein rechtsradikalen Rest der
ganz schlimm ist über den wir reden
müssen aber 10 15% dieser jetzigen
Anhängerschaft auch wagenknechtpartei
werteunion freie wähle AFD ist Unmut
über eine widersprüchliche
Ideologie harte Politik dieser Ampel
immer dann wenn es konkret wird kommt
ihr auf die Metaebene und das ist das
speist die AFD Wähler das ist aus meiner
Sicht der Hauptgrund dann hätten wir
sonst nur noch mit einem rechten harten
Kern zu tun und dann kann man auch über
andere Maßnahmen reden aber Bröcker die
Frage wie wir unsere Bildungssystem
finanzieren und wie viele Schüler und
Schülerinnen eine Lehrerin eine Frage
das ist keine metafrage das ist eine
ganz konkrete Frage weil deuts
Grundschule gerade Thema und nicht die
Gelder für oder Bund dazu habe ich noch
überhaupt gar nichts gesagt ich finde
natürlich müssen wir in Deutsch
Grundschulen haben dass jeder grundschul
gen wenn es die deutsche Sprache nicht
lernt diese deutsche Sprache lernen muss
das ist für mich eigentlich
Selbstverständlichkeit Gegenteil ist in
Deutschland der Fall gehen Sie mal in
die
Grundschule tatschlich sehhr großes
Problem haben und das wäre dann ja auch
was wenn wir über Sprachkurse reden wenn
wir über die Frage reden wer macht die
eigentlich wie viele Leute erreichen die
da die Kind Kinder reden denn
tatsächlich Sprache ist der hauptschul
Integration das ist gar keine Frage ich
glaube der zweite ist Arbeit aber das
erste Sprache das zweite ist Arbeit nur
vielleicht können wir ein bisschen davon
wegkommen dass sie sind der Meinung dass
ich eine ideologische Politik vertrete
und gleich automatisch ihnen immer
unterstellen würde dass das jetzt
rassistisch wäre ich glaube auch diese
dauernde vorwürf diese unterstellen ja
jedem sofort ich glaube ich habe keinen
von den beiden bei irgendwas was sie
gerade gesagt haben weder Rass no
irgendw
felichit ich glaube nur das ist der
haupritikpunkt an den an der Ampel an
der grünen ist tatsächlich dass sie das
Menschen das Gefühl haben ihr wollt eine
Energiewende ihr wollt eine vololl
Elektrifizierung aber schaltet die
Atomenergie ab dass die ständig immer
das Gefühl ihr wollt irgendwie mehr
Leute in Arbeit bringen aber schraubt
das Bürgergeld nach oben und schraubt
die Rentner früher in in den Ruhestand
die Leute haben das Gefühl ja die ihre
Ziele sind doch richtig und gut ich
würde euch gerne unterstützen aber warum
macht ihr dann das Gegenteil ich versu
nur das zu analysieren ich sag nicht
dass das alles stimt no ganz
konkrete dürfen sofort gerne noch mal
Fragen wissen sie ungefähr wie hoch ist
die Durchschnittsrente Deutschland
Durchschnittsrente Ken ich tatsächlich
nicht haben Sie eine Idee nee
tatsächlich keine konkrete
ungefähr ich würde davon ausgehen dass
wir um die 2000 € umliegen
Durchschnittsrente
153 € das ist noch mal ein Stück
geringer nach 45 Jahren Arbeit ist das
gerecht nein was machen wir dagegen was
wir gerade als Ampel Plan sind ja zwei
Dinge die jetzt auf den Weg gebracht
werden das eine ist die Stabilisierung
des rentennive also sozusagen eine
untere Haltelinie zu schaffen das andere
ist mit der aktienrente noch mal einen
Zusatz zu schaffen mit der Versicherung
aber was tatsächlich der Hauptpunkt ist
an den wir ran müssen ist die Frage wie
viele Menschen zahlen ein und wer
profitiert am Ende von dem was angezahlt
wird denn wir haben ja ein riesenpr in
diesem Land und das ist demografischer
Wandel das heißt wir haben eine
Entwicklung wo der Anteil von denen der
Rente ist immer größer wird der Anteil
von denen die immer einz mal kleiner das
heißt die Frage von Erwerbsarbeit und
dann natürlich auch wie viel verdienen
diese Leute das ist die Hauptfrage bei
der Stabilität der Rente und natürlich
muss man dann auch über konkrete
Unterstützung sprechen wird wird gern
zum Schluss noch mal Frau lang viele
dieser Themen über die wir gerade
sprechen und die die Leute zurecht
beklagen sind geerbte Themen die haben
sie gar nicht
sozusagen zu verantworten letztenendes
aber Sie müssen jetzt damit umgehen und
deswegen finde ich immer das muss muss
man auch mit erwähnen das ist auch
wichtig das klarzuziehen aber sie hätten
dennoch die Chance jetzt wo sie doch im
Amt sind und in Verantwortung sind
hätten sie die Chance viel Dinge zu
verändern können Sie nachvollziehen dass
manches auch das eine oder andere was
wir gerade diskutiert haben auch gerade
in ihrer Partei wahnsinnig abgehoben
wirkt und die Leute da unten das Gefühl
haben die verstehen uns gar nicht mehr
das ist das Gefühl dass gerade die
Bauern auf die Straße getrieben hat und
vieles vieles mehr die verstehen z.B
nicht warum wir so viel Geld für
Migration ausgeben aber die eine
Milliarde die da jetzt unbedingt gekürzt
werden muss die haben wir dann nicht
mehr da in diesem Bundes Haushalt können
Sie das nachvollziehen dass das
abgehoben wird noch einmal ganz Kur
migrationsthema weil ich finde
tatsächlich der Zusammenhang der hier
zwischen Migration und Wirtschaft
aufgemacht wird ist kein richtiger wir
werden in den nächsten Jahren übrigens
selbst W es hinbekommen mit den
Jugendlichen die bisher un schulabschutz
die Schule verlassen werden wir ein
massives wirtschaftliches Problem haben
wenn wir es nicht schaffen dass Menschen
hierherkommen Arbeit aber Investition in
sinnvolle Arten von Migration und auch
die Arbeitsmarktintegration von Menschen
die Sch sind sind am Ende ein
Stabilitätsfaktor für unsere Wirtschaft
wenn wir es richtig machen wenn wir es
realistisch machen und ja wenn wir es
auch kontrolliert machen das für mich
keine Frage aber zu der Frage die sie
gerade gestellt haben ich glaube
tatsächlich dass wir manchmal eine
Tendenz haben ins technokratische zu
verfallen in dem Moment wo man sich sich
ich meine das haben wir gemerkt bei der
debattumsgebäude Energiegesetzen ich
kann das ganz offen über mich ganz
persönlich sagen da war man in einem
Verteidigungsmodus wollte das irgendwie
erklären und dann wird es unfassbar
technokratisch und da stehen Leute die
haben reale Ängste die haben realale
Sorgen was passiert eigentlich in meinem
Keller was wie kann ich mir das
eigentlich leisten dann kommen wir und
erklären Ihnen im kleinsten Detail wie
das alles technisch geht da entsteht ein
mismatch und da entsteht dann glaube ich
auch ein Vertrauensverlust in Politik
und das war es was ich vorher mit
Emotion meinte das ist kein
ablenkungsmoment sonder dabei geht es
für mich darum zu sagen an der
Lebensrealität der Menschen und die ist
auch eine emotionale die ist nicht immer
nur rational die ist nicht immer durch
Zahlen getrieben sondern an dieser
Lebensrealität anzuknüpfen denn am Ende
glaube ich müssen schon wir Grüne klar
machen wir machen Politik halt nicht
weil wir Dinge gut wissen und auch nicht
weil wir sie besser wissen sie haben ja
recht wenn sie sagen es ist ein bisschen
populistisch sozusagen einfach den
Zusammenhang zwischen Migration und und
den treckerfahrenden Bauern herzustellen
haben sie ja prinzipiell recht nur die
Leute machen das natürlich so und die
Leute verstehen es nicht weil es für sie
auch ganz konkret ist sitzen Sie
manchmal zusammen und reden über so
Projekte die in den letzten Wochen auch
öffentlich geworden sind ich war
fasziniert davon dass wir 300 Millionen
für Radwege und Busse in Peru ausgeben
das stimmt ja offenkundig das finde ich
interessant und darüber können wir sogar
noch reden wir geben aber auch z.B
600.000 € aus für die Stärkung von
Toleranz in Indonesien ich glaube stimmt
das die konkrete Zahl kenne ich nicht
aber wenn sie Vorlesen
würde aus für 6 Millionen für
Umweltschutz in Albanien wir geben 260
000 € für kleine Kakaobauern in Afrika
aus finde ich gut wir geben 10 Millionen
für Waldbewirtschaftung im Kongobecken
aus auch okay 500.000 € für die
Förderung Achtung positiver Maskulinität
in
Ruanda können sie sich sowas vorstellen
ich kann mir das vorstellen aber ich
finde e das was ihr gerade unterstellen
ist wenn wir was für
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit ausgeehen
dann ist das verlorenes Geld dann ist
das Geld das wir hier rausgeorfen darum
geht's nicht es geht um die Frage ob sie
verstehen dass man wenn wenn Menschen
sowas dann lesen dass sie sagen was
machen die da eigentlich das ist ja
deutsches Steuergeld
das in Konkurrenz zu China wo shiin Ping
mit seiner
seitenstraßeninitiative eigentlich viel
mehr Geld dahinschickt aber auch viel
mehr Geld rausholt und letztendlich
diese Länder es ihm viel mehr danken
weil er halt irgendwie da die Straßen
gebaut werden und Ölpipelines weiß ich
was China kriegt übrigens von uns 86
Millionen Entwicklungshilfe das nur mal
am Rande ich glaube dass ich als
Politikerin in so einer Situation zwei
Optionen habe ich kann natürlich sagen
ach das klingt erstmal alles absurd und
dann rede ich den Leuten da ein bisschen
nach Mund und sag ja ja das stimmt alles
und füt ein bisschen dies
und dann stellen wir uns alle hin und
können uns freuen oder ich stehe dazu
was wir politisch tun versuche es zu
erklären und ver allem auch vielleicht
dann auch mal aufzuzeigen wenn wir mit
reden da waren gerade auch zwei Ding
dabei ich GL Waldschutz in Albanien
genannt Schutz in Albanien und 10
Millionen für für den Kongo we es gibt
auch noch mal eine halbe Million für
ökofeministische
entwicklungsalternativen in sü sind
Dinge von denen wir sehr konkret
profitieren weil ehrlicherweise
Zerstörung Umwelt nee sie lachen da aber
nein das sind keine Dinge die do
reintional nur über diese Formulierung
weil ich mich frage was ökofeministische
entwicklungsalternativen sein sollicht
sie das ist aus der Abteilung skoriles
aber schwer zu verstehen und die Leute
sind halt auch informiert und die würden
gerne wissen wie wir das in Zukunft Hand
haben